nope got my coffee chin yeah
Brian yeah I don't think you say happy
Memorial Day it's not a happy mom well
look it doesn't tribute to them it's a
tribute that then falls to the men and
women who fought for this country and a
country I want to say this about
Memorial deco in the history of military
a country defines itself a nation
defines itself on what it's willing to
fight for and I think a person does as
well so it's a it's an important time
when people went off and made the
ultimate sacrifice and died you know and
spend a lot of time away from their
families and pay the price for that too
maybe I was thinking shout out to all
that you know I was thinking is uh
wouldn't society be better especially
America if you had to enlist in the
military if you had to live a life like
that it's a very good question take more
pride in our nation and like I I don't
think there'd be as much hate I don't
think there would be as much toxic like
a toxic environment on social media if
everyone had to serve in the military
cuz you learn like you kind of learn
discipline you learn the value of life
some guys like the majority of go to
third world countries you see what other
people they're like yeah you there's
huge discipline you have to work as a
team yep you realize what matters yeah
you're not you know in your mom's
basement criticizing those who are doing
things that you would never think of
doing yeah you know like you don't see a
lot of military guys hating hating on
the Internet well I don't know I I do
think that's always been a contentious
issue and we did have a draft look up
how long we had a draft in this country
and I think after Vietnam was when
things got stopped right yeah when
Muhammad Ali up see how this well he
yeah he had the balls that was a pretty
ballsy thing for him to do hundred but
but at the end of the day the droughts
that draft came to an end when the
United States Armed Forces moved to an
all-volunteer military force however the
Selective Service System remains in
place as a contingency plan many male
citizens between the ages of 18 and 25
required register so that a draft can be
readily resumed if needed
there you go draft ends 19 after Vietnam
that's right there yeah so so this
country's always had a very contentious
issue in terms of there was always the
worry that a standing army a standing
army in this country would be
historically abused so in throughout
history when you had a standing army you
had an army that was ready to go a
charismatic leader would come to power
like Napoleon and take control of that
standing army to then control the
population of the population it's just
what would happen yeah you always have a
charismatic dude Sherwood who would
figure out a way to control the
molineres
yeah everyone everyone and still goes on
this in this in the world today and the
United States would that that was the
large question but we had to ultimately
have a standing army because we had you
have threats from the British we had to
be a yeah yeah but we were surrounded by
oceans so we had the luxury of having
time to deal with that but but I think
III do agree that if you had a military
draft I think a lot of people would gain
a great deal from it especially young
men clothes all that aggression anyway
yeah and and and and by the way also
maybe it would also when you got when
you are put in the military from save
the age of 18 to 20 what are you doing
those years anyway you're trouble
trouble it keeps you out of trouble
properly but also you learn kind of a
foundation of how you should kind of
live the rest of your life
respect that worked well with others
working well with others being exposed
to like you said to other countries a
condition as a guy who grew up all over
the world if everybody in this country
would just spend one month abroad any
work just to see how other people live
we'd have a very different foreign
policy but about first have you ever met
like a melt like a real military guy
who's just a tool I haven't I probably
had them from a military family yeah
yeah I haven't well one of the just you
know just like guys yeah ever so one of
these I said to my dad after after well
I'm sure they're out there I've never
met him my father was a marine and
always talks about this and and one of
things I notice about when I went to
Afghanistan with with Steve Byrne and
Duff Davidoff and Sam Tripoli you know
we went on that USAO tour was amazing
one of things I noticed about being in a
war zone
was that it's
all about the dude or the gal next to
you you come last it's it's it's country
it's its platoon you know it's outfit
and then it's ultimately you come last
but so when you see dudes in a war zone
everybody will say they're a bunch of
bags and a truck the one thing I noticed
is that they are they everybody helps
it's like you don't even think about
you're not getting your bag you're
getting other bags first yeah so
everything about that coming from
Hollywood and I've been in Hollywood for
so long where it's all about you it's
all about narcissus it's just about you
know you are the center of your universe
because that's reward yeah yeah in in
the military it's the exact opposite and
there's something very refreshing and
guys get a guy's anyhow get addicted to
that community that thing were your Hall
and when you're in a war zone you're
always afraid and you have to rely on
each other you create real bombs in
stress situation in the breath create
yeah what you actually produce oxytocin
which is a bonding chemical and I say
the close thing I've never been in
combat but the close thing would be you
fight in the UFC you guys go through
this weird experience that only you two
can go through I don't I'd love to see
the science behind that maybe there's
there I mean you release the same toxin
you do is my toxins it's a it's a
chemical so it's a bonding cancel on the
kids about bonding hormone called
oxytocin that assuming that woman their
baby that's what gotcha
and so I'm assuming you developed the
same release body when you go through
that stress even if the guy beat me up
say Travis Browne whoever it was there
I've gone in the back and there was no
anger there's no resentment well think
about it go we both know but think about
you and I like like think about the bond
like of starting out with the with Joe
when Rogan told you to stop fighting
yeah the decision to keep doing the
podcast to let it out that [ __ ] is all
that stuff stressful when it's happening
it's not pleasant and there was a lot of
unknown with us how about when I called
you and the guy got us kicked out of Fox
remember that yeah a lot of it's on me
Michael Browns like way
well remember with that well I might
have made some animation like you're
like oh yeah
we've been locked out of our we got
locked out we just couldn't even go into
the building
well we gotta figure some out man you're
like oh well yeah I guess we'll be just
our ride or die here here we go yeah man
so I do think that a dry I've always
kind of felt like a draft but again a
good nature right you're making you're
also forcing people you know to join
government military outfit at the same
time look at the way like those
countries have a draft most countries
have a draft but also like the way our
societies go to switch through the
younger generation ain't good like look
out toxic social medias it's variable I
don't know that being in the military
would I do think that a lot of people
say give them perspective yeah I do
think a lot of people from the age of 18
to you know somebody said if you want to
get rid of all the crime in the country
all you got to do is just take every 14
year old boy and keep him in basically a
military like outfit from 14 to 20
you'll have zero violent crime because
that's that's it that's the age that so
I don't know say that some say be up to
you can't we're not gonna do that
I don't think and here's the thing let's
say we go to war with Iraq which we
might get drum stupid enough Iran Iran
let's say we're able to do that shout to
run let's say we're gonna do that and
your son was a disaster and your son was
18 yeah yeah I'm like sorry he's in the
draft I'd like no he's not well so that
was that was tough for that be if that's
your kid that was the scarring of
Vietnam where so many people came back
and they didn't even know where it was
on the map and they went I'm going to
Vietnam and those guys that went we lose
54,000 tizen and and a lot of them came
back weren't the same anymore and we
just were like and then we were like but
wait it didn't do anything oh wait the
North invaded the south in this
economy's country and wait you guys told
us that we had to stop we had to stop
this domino effect so the idea do you
know yeah we have stopped the domino
effect as the world's being taken over
by communists or if we don't stop them
here we did it in Lebanon we did in
Greece so now we got to do it again in
Vietnam we did it we did in Korea we
start we did it in North and versus
South Korea we have to either
a big outcry right like they don't want
that's why Vietnam was so well there are
things that we were winning the war I
mean did the fact that matters the US
military fought very well in Vietnam and
the Tet Offensive was actually a huge
success by America it was a huge success
when the Viet Cong tried to take over
but but when you saw it on camera when
you saw it on camera it looked like we
got our asses kicked and it changed the
way the American public looked at the
war but so who's the turning point was
broadcasting that because if it was
coming for Walter Cronkite but wypall
why broadcasts us losing like why not
paint the picture like we're wasn't that
we were losing but what made what made
news was the sensational stuff the
pictures of a girl on fire huh after a
napalm attack as she's running toward
the camera Americans went what the [ __ ]
is what and seeing the the caskets and
seeing the military the young men who
were wounded horribly and killed that
was that came into American living rooms
and it and it sparked and it's parked
massive protec was the first time Hey
yeah World War two not read forties you
know that's like in broadcast well
remembers on the rape and remember in
World War two the fundamental difference
was that we were flying enemy we were
fighting the Japanese and Germans who
would Japanese had attacked yes they had
attacked us look at that look at that
misery I don't see those Jim it's
changed you ever think about going the
military no the reason I'm in this
country is because of that reason my
parents didn't want me to go to the
military yeah oh because in Korea you
have to enlist yeah my dad he did like
two years yeah I think hard service in a
military the Korean men are the Koreans
are very hard men the code the culture
expects hardness out of their men yeah
you just know that there are tough women
don't have to do anything right the
Korean Tigers who fought in Vietnam were
the period name they were feared they
were pretty badass the guys I know who
served in Vietnam said that the the
people that they thought could endure
the most the biggest hardship with the
Koreans they were just like the Korean
Tigers were just like [ __ ] they blew
their mind they were just like they were
all like all like Navy SEALs do you know
what you know I found myself doing I
started watching this TV series called
Chernobyl on HBO or no you know I'm
talking about or that was the meltdown
of the nuke
reactor correct and they covered it up
you know I found myself doing this
regurgitating what you say about Russia
to Joanna and her family I'm like you
know they just suppress the people name
one name one piece of art name one thing
that Russia comes up with go ahead go
I'll wait I was doing exactly you doing
that I was like name one thing they make
that we use go ahead yeah I'll wait
that's commodity like what I was like
lumber my lumber we got market that's it
drink their vodka yeah we don't drink it
no they suppress their creative this is
what happens soon as I get done act like
I own doable that's a country that's a
country where it where my face right
right anything else yeah that's a
good-ass here it's only three episodes
long yet but it is fascinating in that
can and I think you can go on a tour of
Chernobyl yeah and radioactive right
yeah it's but you know what the the the
area around that I guess has become a
park where there are wolves bears like
its thriving while I need rewiring yeah
thriving why it is fascinating the when
you watch the reason why it's fast names
because it's just a true all that's true
story so you watch like what dumb no one
lives there I couldn't believe it man I
could not believe it it's so good it's
so well done it's on HBO I got to see it
yeah 23 episodes long dude now like Game
of Thrones ease is done Game of Thrones
ease is done yeah American Idols over
and some TV in you know I don't have you
don't know what to I don't have and I've
had some free time right with the
holidays that it's not much I just
started you know that mom mother Daris
there's a documentary on HBO called
mother dearest who do you know I'm
talking about I know my mom that made
the Robert Joan Crawford ah the shoe
made her daughter believe she was sick
all the time
um and to get free things and they'll
share the dollar shins disease yes yeah
and then the daughter kills the mom
murders the mom and she got out I think
she just got a prison she's doing ten
years but the mom would make her you
know pretend like she's real sick all
the time and then finally she came
around she's like what the [ __ ] I'm not
sick and the mom were like fed her all
these pills and she they went like
hundred different hospitals and then
finally someone picked up on it was like
she's fine what's going on
here and then she had yeah that that's
whatever you call our girl fan munchkins
and so hurt her boyfriend and I think
that the boyfriend killed the mother
spoiler this happened [ __ ] ten years
ago so suck it but uh so they did a
series on Hulu I've never had Hulu
before I just got Hulu first of all it's
dope commercials kind of killing me
slowly but the actress looks I [ __ ]
Danakil to the real girl it's on Hulu
yeah I forget what it's called chin poor
girl
but the same the same mom who plays on
escaped in Dannemora you don't tell him
out in Showtime escape from Dannemora
yeah oh I'm Patricia Arquette oh she's
so good in this yeah so that's the real
one that's not much that's not it
that's on HBO but Mommy Dearest
the at that act look up when you go to
images go back up to us ain't it bro
piss in it go to the act and then type
didn't go to images right there the girl
looks [ __ ] spa hotter so far left
look at the girl man it's spot-on she's
so good in this Wow
Patricia Arquette so she's so good a
good actress she's actually pretty yes
yes Wow
makeup hater that's her in the show that
look at the really how good she looked
compared to the real one
they looked identical that mom wishes
she looked like Patricia could have damn
what a horrible so I think she's doing
you can be born into the wrong to the
wrong parent so she told her since she
was a kid all your legs don't work and
so she's like oh my legs
so just she got mentally conditioned my
legs I'm always sick and her mom but had
a feeding tube in her stomach wide feet
oh yeah all fake kid was perfectly fine
you gotta watch it up watch documentary
and then watch the act on her but the
documentary like what the [ __ ]
so when they can [ __ ] so they gave her I
think 10 years should see how long she
got pretty sure they give the daughter
10 years let her out what do you mean 10
years
you you deal with that and she killed a
she her boyfriend she talked her
boyfriend to killing her ah murder of
DeeDee Blanchard they uh she's a tractor
that had baked you big dome horrifying
well daughter's name what he was gypsy
right yeah yeah gypsy yeah I said how
did Gypsy Rose kill her mother you see
it down there yeah click on they're
eligible for parole in 2023 should be
twenty three years under her she is ten
years that's [ __ ] it is weird they
give her ten years right let her out can
be killing people though it is
fascinating the poor thing it's been
destroyed
how about her [ __ ] of a mom terrible
mom but and they would like con people
so they got a house they built him a
house because of her sickness of course
yeah like freed the mom would shave her
head all the time so she looked sick the
mom told her she was allergic to sugar
if she had anything should have an
EpiPen so like she would like steel on
her own like cupcakes and try them the
mom saw in front of tons of people
grabbed a EpiPen and shot her in the leg
ah like the mom's [ __ ] crazy had a
whole cupboard full of [ __ ] pills and
the kid I'll see if you don't need the
medication you're taking I feel like
[ __ ] yeah so the kids always in a
wheelchair shaped head feeling like [ __ ]
just dump it pills what a way to grow up
what a [ __ ] way to grow up what a
piece of [ __ ] what a terrible mom man
yeah well she's she's a diseased human
being she's an evil you were born to a
witch you were born to a witch she knew
where man she's a witch
she got dealt with though she got to
hell she got killed stabbed multiple
times in the back oh really yes yeah I
am I think sometimes murder is not such
a terrible thing
pretty girl who kidnapped a
five-year-old and he's not being
cooperative and they know he knows where
she is the uncle and he's some young
dude
and I would let me get in there let me
get in there with that without God I'll
get your [ __ ] ass cuffs frustrate
I'll get your answer I'll make that guy
nothing why are you two up serious
either
yeah Jesus Christ guys what we're doing
no one's seen it I've seen a law and
order SVU yeah I don't like watching
these things I can't do it iris all I
need to know
well this one's good because it's so
interesting because she's obviously the
gypsy's better now yeah she's just
fishing although she looked kind of
she's away from the [ __ ] crazy mom
yeah
Shuggie but she could have real food
hopefully she had Russia rebuild her
life at 32 you're me pretty [ __ ] up
cuz she thought she was 14 when she's
really 18 the mom lied to her on her age
and she's kind of cute she's attractive
well uh in the in the TV series yeah she
definitely is well no in real life the
person whose arrest is not terrible
mm-hmm mm-hmm
amen let me see you kid again Gypsy Rose
right yeah Gypsy Rose Sarah the teeth
are a little tough but [ __ ] Freddie
Mercury figured it out all right there's
your rest their house news you go to
Gypsy Rose nudes she's cute poor thing
least her eyes are sad some baggage at
some baggage Brennan um go to see the
boy Oh Tara go to the boyfriend that's
the one who did it
that's what every troll on internet
looks like yeah he's got so much he
looks like he does yeah
yes poor girl that poor girl
that poor girl right think about what
she's been through man well well happy
now I saw Aladdin this weekend prettiest
all under ten please it was missing the
magic of Disney but I'll give it a solid
eight Wow will its Will Smith was good
yeah so now the problem is is Robin
Williams in it before him which is one
of the ultimate greats but he did his
own so you got Robin Williams over well
there's Justin I love both them they're
just different it stopped when someone
does it fer
then you got to recreate it yeah but he
wills really really good amazing and
jasmine
I don't know jasmine you know who Jeff
you know bring up Jasmine she is on Jeff
die me dime dime sickle you'd have to by
the way how about Will Smith still still
doing it yeah and killing it 5-0
killing it Princess Jasmine the real
Princess Jasmine
she is I'm a-looking I'm alike yeah well
hello hey Naomi Scott I know I see it's
uh go to images tell you there's no
actress that's Jasmine this guy she's
cute
yeah look at that little Jasmine she's a
she could write write write and buy
carpet I mean dick oops
whoopsie-daisy um she's pretty you know
who's you know I'm what my dad never
said my dad never sat down at this agent
you went man my legs and ass are [ __ ]
sore and I buried he says he wasn't
doing lunges and squats
dude I am uh yeah here if I'm my the
memory the men of the last generation
my dad said and I am he's in shape he is
he weird we were you were sweat my house
my goddamn Papa yeah
leader anions have fat on him no I'm so
I went running uh two days ago I'm so
[ __ ] sore man you are ah so sore and
then it was like I went at 7:00 a.m. so
the Sun wasn't out yet and I was running
and tight well and there was a sign for
mountain lions I'm like so then I had my
headphones in I'm like I don't know man
I've been stressed too because the
specialists doing everything around that
I've been real stressed I was running I
was like what if I'm at Lincoln I
thought I've been watching a bunch like
circular stuff I saw one guy on the
trail who looked super suspect now so
then I was like have a feels a gun and
then I keep going I'm like I'd be so
easy to kill me yeah you're mountain
lions not biting you mountain lions not
coming after you you're too big that's
what I that's what I can't attack women
and stuff are small step for the
- gentlemen those two gentlemen in
Seattle who had killed one
what come on dude you know her this when
it was that in Seattle two dudes not
small this mountain line went well I'm
starving and these only two numbnuts I
see so they do what the experts tell you
make it loud put your bet bike up so
they put their bike up the mountain lion
goes very cool that is a cool bike so we
look at them they look delicious but
still so the mountain lion goes cool
bike sir guys we fightin because I'm
starving
starts attacked it jumps on one they
seem like hunting them right Wow jumps
on one the friend goes oh no oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna run and get help see I'm like it
help you he starts to run the mat line
goes where the [ __ ] are you going kills
him slaughter eats him alive you stop
other guy gets away they come they call
the cops they come back all they finds
that guy's [ __ ] head what yep and he
carried the body up into like the tree
so of course they killed him outline but
those who's grown wrong that man I was
starving
it's a little different kind of a story
about Lions ruling for lesbians I didn't
it says they identified as men is that
was Jane Brooks 32 has been identified
as man killed well he's not a he's a man
he's a trans woman oh who knows it
doesn't make sense you look very he's a
hundred something pound I'll fit they
don't look they don't you put up the
biggest fight right they don't look they
don't look like like I would fight them
in a bar I wouldn't fight you in a bar
you know I mean the point is Brian Deese
mountain lions will attack now a
mountain lion will [ __ ] you up
I'm al my I see you got 140 pound mat
lines you seen a hundred pound police
dogs Oh
how about we start will destroy you
didn't think about a mountain lion old
saying that's a large human in the
mountain lion wasn't scared of him you
get the point bro that's oh okay it says
right there who co-founded friends on
bikes Seattle to create bike community
where women trans femme non-binary
people of coke
Oh of color can come together and have
fun on bikes so that does the Creator so
the mountain line
homophobic apparently well the mountain
lion said that person looks like a
gentler spirit I knew that fair the
Mallo it
I don't smelt the saucer around and he
got tits I'm gonna eat those yeah that's
what happened looks like so that's the
guy who died yeah girl gallo and without
but that guy gal is also the one that
went oh [ __ ] my friends can attacked SIA
and ran off sleek I'm gonna get out
people tell you no he wasn't either one
who was eaten oh yeah you know why
because as the friend was getting
attacked you survived while he/she was
running I don't know the right person
they say the cool both of them yes
because when she took off running or he
whatever he pronouns she wants to use
when she took off running the mountain
line went well where the [ __ ] you going
and then killed her while the other one
got away
oh but because she took off their
running its prey killed that one the
other one got away the one on the right
got away so they scared off the first
time they got off their bikes scared it
off the first time when they got back on
it attacked one of them so it attacks
when they got back on the yeah so
someone told that at one point his
entire head was inside the Cougars mouth
when his friend began to run away the
Cougar dropped him and chased Brooks he
then wrote his bike see a friend to try
and find reception mmm-hmm the injured
man called 911 just after 11 a.m.
can you hear me help the call then cut
out first responders who were standing
there you go first runner said the
Cougar was standing over Brooks when the
thirty discovered his body the Cougar
had actually dragged the victim back to
the wood line and he was found dead
there yeah damn Wow
what a terrible way to go keep scrolling
down tunes or more details here's my
thing is that this a cougar doing cougar
[ __ ] yes they always want to kill it
like has the taste of human organs just
starving starving certain cultures
certain genders are associated with
bicycling even though those people do
buy okay yeah the cooler didn't give a
[ __ ] about your bike mess and no nor
should he know my point is when I'm out
there seven or more
running him I got Brian I got short
shorts on that Reebok sent me I got my
cheeks hanging out the front dick peace
in the fought your cheeks with me hang
out the friar back you got it you gotta
be specific so then I get very complete
oh I see I'm standing yeah she's hanging
out the back door running backwards
maybe you're running backwards and
that's sometimes I am not safe sometimes
I am though bro so hear me out here yeah
and I don't have service there either
GPS yeah I get my cheeks out the back
yeah front pterodactyl hanging out the
front cold and I'm running turned out my
[ __ ] my quads are pulsating your knob
is bouncing up and down correct yeah I
tater-tots them and you got pole height
you got a tight sack cause it's cold and
when you run I got shot bottom and I got
a pink bike hat on oh boy I'll have
sunglasses oh boy I think the tiger
could go hold up I thought we got rid of
this by Hoover and not the tiger who's
there in India that will kill you you
don't want to [ __ ] around tea grace no
no that's never wrong
tigré never buy muck about man or
whether it's like it's like Frank Grillo
was in Africa and he and they go where
are you going and he goes I'm gonna go
for a run and they said well you're not
gonna go for a run well you're not
because there are Lions out in this
world yeah I think it's but I'm just
gonna go around there go no no no see
when you're running your prey and you'll
die only 5 330 pound 1 pound cat in here
and peep out of you in here and a peep
out of any human you look delicious does
anyone else think I get well I was
running I I was actually consumed me for
most of my run that someone's gonna
either kill me or about Lindsey and get
me because if they kill me out in those
trails they I'm not telling you
I take there's nothing out there shirts
where Kanye pulls his gospel but they
wouldn't find me there they take me
somewhere else I was in one easy to get
rid of me yeah
and like if some guy was just like snipe
remember the Malibu killer mare that the
mountain you just killed like a family
that's camping and they found a guy for
his dad for if forever they catch him
finally they thought they think they
caught him they did catch him finding
I'm not saying it yeah let's say there
was a [ __ ]
Calabasas killer yeah he's gonna get
away like man man charged with murder
yeah they always find him I like I
always find them right always they're
amazing
let's see if we can see him I was in I
was in Wyoming with my girlfriend
we were hiking me my girl my friend and
his wife I was a young man sure
now we're in big whiskey Mountain where
there are good Grizzlies okay now we
were hiking we saw grizzly tracks ooh I
did mushrooms lost all my clothing it a
lot of berries and came down just
sneakers totally naked a bit ridiculous
terrible mouth I bet you dick on that
trip in the net worth at all I was I was
hugging rocks it was very high yeah I
was on mushrooms now that night they've
worn off we've hung out my girl in the
tent gets her period the one thing you
don't want look at that guy look at that
cool piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah he's a
crazy person who kills just gonna put
him down
I agree toss him in a cage with a
[ __ ] mountain lion man that's the guy
that let him eat you so you're back to
your storage area girls about to
socialize all that Annika so when you do
one thing you don't want to have as your
period in grizzly country when all areas
between you and Grizzlies at night is a
tiny thin because they can smell the
mental side got a good is what they said
on them so she was so [ __ ] afraid so
afraid and we had uno gun
uno gun gun yeah that ain't stopping a
beer no and she was so afraid and I was
trying to be brave and I was like don't
worry I didn't have the gun
my friend had his gun we just stayed in
that tent and we kept hearing terrified
at night you hear this does it make you
horny though yes
we better figure that as that because I
was the man yeah and I did some banging
she was terrified by I was like this
might help even though she's on her
period this when I feel sick Bryan
Callen whoops is that a grizzly oops is
that your booty holes that is sleeping
bag grizzly whoops are we go into
Browntown
well I'm not talking about the Bears Oh
got about two going in South I don't
even think I did that I just was like I
will deal with the old or yeah I'm a man
anyway
either way you just got after it huh did
your friend what do unit a number I
don't remember if we got after it but
it's a good story she was just so
terrified is when I was running to I'm
like if I get murdered right now or a
mountain lion does kill me a I'm gonna
get roasted online by people because I
got murdered by mountain lion be Rogen's
be like I [ __ ] told you carry a knife
I remember telling me like you're gonna
run up there I always have a knife on me
yeah I just don't you're gonna run with
a big [ __ ] knife I ain't doing [ __ ]
against AG if your head if it's mano y
mano it's on top a that knife you might
wanna have keys yeah that's what he said
I guess but my brother a bear spray
alright man you just go for a run I
don't want spray here I don't wanna
[ __ ] knife is it good look up bow down
my back watch this guy in guy jogging
and anything it was in Canada mountain
lion comes running out and he just goes
that and he sprays the thing video he
does it run back yeah it just he stops
it short with spray you know what the
other thing is I've run with headphones
so here's all I'm even here I'm jammed
under sprays bear bro cougar yeah
are you talking oh there it is there it
is right there the top one cam a
frightening leak close encounter in
northwestern Alberta a man out for an
evening jog found himself face to face
with two Cougars on a remote Alberta
Canada three kilometres behind the
camera phone is Donnie stone the 35 year
old was running near his work camp when
he spotted two Cougars down the trail I
know there's lots around but I've never
seen one so I've always wanted to see
one an avid runner stone takes part in
events like the death race and sinister
seven he says runners are given tips to
deal with a cougar encounter I was
expecting quite honestly for them to
just stay in the bush and watch me go by
he continued cautiously back towards
safety I'm in your prey always from
behind
[Music]
it would even like this alright I like
try to attack him fellas like yeah have
a good day yeah fine its face dude yeah
that's that is strong super strong like
God [ __ ] dude I was literally crossing
the street with my girl you piece of
[ __ ] two Cougars waiting boy they would
[ __ ] up with my mom and two cops I'll
get you some food
or a husband and why you gotta have
spray spray they say is more effective
than the guns for sure especially with
big Grizzlies dude Jesus grizzly game
set match mmm bear spray
that's how large that's a serious spray
to look at I stopped my used to bring my
son with me out there but I'm like
because when you see the signs from
outlines long they definitely like
Yahtzee I was like I'm good with you
I'll see him back at the crib yeah but
if you have him in your what do you
carry him a knapsack no man I some three
dude he likes to run with me yeah yeah
worried about that stuff yeah
rattlesnakes yeah mountain lions
perverts perverts like inhale I worry
about the real people like if I was a
serial killer I would hang out on trails
that's what I was thinking dude or get
dark why we're on Halloween I just
pretend I'm part of the haunted house
and then I'd murder people and everyone
thinks it's a big act and cuz everything
looks like murder in there hmm oh yeah
oh yeah I told you that time I was
trick-or-treating with me and my friends
kid and we were all all of us there guy
sticks a [ __ ] you know the kind of
long saw used to you you cut branches
yeah sticks that out of the [ __ ]
sticks it out of the door
I'll blade what do you mean he's
stuck a [ __ ] blade out like with
trigger trainees off a real blade and
then I go I go I grab both of them that
blade right there I go viral one of the
in the woman came out and said you
shouldn't trick-or-treat oh the for [ __ ]
and trick-or-treating houses I don't
know about really and I said I'll murder
you I'll murder in the shake come at me
I said we should call the cops but then
I would for sure that's what he n yeah
stuck that out so strange with little
children how about I kill you how about
I kill all of you in that house could
kill them is your you will no barbecues
today right for you guys families no
does your family do anything cat uh well
any chance they get to drink and party
they're like they're drinking and
partying yeah really but in San
Francisco until I say yeah San Jose
yours chin do not don't do anything
yours do anything I tried having
barbecue yesterday it rained B yeah I
bought like two racks of ribs you know
heart isn't make ribs you ever made ribs
no dude I thought my dumbass thought I
got from Whole Foods I thought I could
just go to the counter it said marinated
so I figured they put in all the work I
just got a grill them don't work like
that homeboy you know smoke those things
for eight to ten hours yeah you'll a
marinate for another few days yep can't
just grill him they were awful me I had
to order food for sure when I go to the
body I say ice cream out back I said out
backs they make ribs there no you see
Chili's Chili's known for the rest I
mean dude you want the best ribs for all
those [ __ ] places and I mean [ __ ] places
TGI Fridays tell me dude I agree my
mouth is watering seriously their ribs
are ridiculous really
now sponsor one well I've been there
once when I was in Edmonton
Kansas City's got some ribs that's all
you need yeah bro Kansas City it takes
to have ribs I'm talking about if you're
trying to go to one these [ __ ]
places really
Chili's fell off Chili's when I was a
kid baby back ribs who was the best now
[ __ ] TGI Fridays doing look at I
damn thing dude look at that
I love ribs when you think I'm
disgusting I haven't had any good ribs
in a long time but good ribs when I mean
they're over the top good oh it's
nothing better you can keep eating them
they're baby blues in Venice there I
think they might have left but
good are they still around I don't know
I always drive by the baby blues that's
that's real is that that's gotta be baby
blues is pretty legit when he when are
you in Denver brothers barbecue some
berry barbecue out there that's right
you [ __ ] up didn't go to brothers mmm
you can't kind of get barbecue of all of
all the main places big blues still
there in Venice yeah that [ __ ] is pretty
delicious Bryan Callen yeah I go there
I'll go there now oh I never got a roast
these what I used to live right there
right there
like across the street from baby blues
yeah I had a house that was walking
distance exactly one minute was baby
blues open then yep never wanted once
cousins snob and I need to start being
such a snob cuz that looks good why
would you be a snob over baby blues now
that's like real single bar we gotta
start spending money on designer food
I'm gonna start eating I need let's
barbecue though bro that's like real
legit I got a style borrow your shite
I'm on that [ __ ] I'm going to kill even
everybody I might even go there after
this sure if they're open on Memorial
Day you know where I went and I forgot
about just uh forgot about good that is
Oh juice is fantastic god damn that I
had this hey when you get a tuna salad
sandwich from there you think it's a
Tuesday it's a whole silver an Ice King
Oh God haven't been to juice in a hot
second I want to scope out the other
week Showtime is in town and we went
there for dinner they said where you
want to go take to celebrate take
anywhere you want I said scalfa since I
don't live down here yeah so I haven't
been there in a while you're so [ __ ]
good Joker you know what I mean I sit I
sit whiskey now like a gentleman okay
well Scopus got a tray gopis got your
whiskey and tequila it like beyond I
think you got the best burp hydral
Buffalo Trace bourbon whiskey okay and I
drink it on ice like a James Buffalo
Trace it's fun as you are either if you
listen if you're a drinker if you're a
drinker of whiskey you can go down that
rabbit hole my boy Aaron only certain
ones though dude my boy Aaron who and
Mishka those those guys who work there
and Aaron listening to the podcast that
dude knows his whiskey he can tell you
he'll back well this is a single batch
and this activist Barrow was actually in
the sons there's Rosie there's one whisk
oh there it is
hold on chin you see the far right my
butt that's why I was no no I'm far left
blanton as
which Jude that's your whiskey it is now
Rogan had it we're sitting back we're
doing the podcast skill I won't do this
the best whiskey I've ever know what
dude that's my whiskey my goat cheese
[ __ ] whiskey that's my that's our
whiskey it's our girl
dude that's that's a beautiful whiskey
and by the way I that's always my go-to
and my boy Brian who has AB helpful and
that's the high end Buffalo yeah that's
high in Buffalo the Buffalo Trace owns
that oh I didn't know yeah I'm pretty
sure cuz I'm all over that blended
coffee grain my Japanese whiskey and
that and they they're not making me any
more you know you know who knows whiskey
like a mother brother J job I bet he
only [ __ ] with Japanese whiskeys Wow
kind of drives me nuts how he's going
Asian on us yeah oh shut the [ __ ] up
he is amazing I'm a Japanese whiskey guy
myself not dude Kentucky Bourbon kidding
that Kentucky by a joke the [ __ ] out of
my face hold on
six-six you got the original single see
the single barrel right there that's
where my boy Aaron Osteria he'll be like
oh really trying hard oh oh my boy
possible from listen my blah blah blah
find my about this we're sitting there
drinking he goes you guys want some you
guys want some real tequila pulls out
the oldest tequila I believe made and
it's like this super so it's 250 bucks a
shot
[ __ ] poured it for us four shots
yeah how's it nice yeah yeah dude plant
I sell it [ __ ] your with you [ __ ] you
tequila well I don't like tequila
Blanton's though original single barrel
not giving it away it's a 300 ala bottle
of whiskey what's the most Spence of
whiskey though Oh Pappy unhappy that
Pappy Van Winkle Winkle $2,500 eat for a
bob happy fan boo twinkle but I don't
think you can buy it anymore honor bucks
a shot they only they only make very
very little 60 G's aqua alive some of
that old Japanese right that's 60 year
old does he's six year old my count con
Louie yeah whiskey think so riff six
year old whiskey fetched a million
dollars but you're paying for like your
pants historicity that has typing up
Pappy Van Winkle's nice of us sneakers
happy happy
Winkle I'm gonna be drinking some of
that June 5th why bas Rutten invited me
to a dinner right down in
I think it's Santa Monica camera what it
how do you know you can be drinking that
the worry about it
that's for teens right that's not how
much is you know has a bottle of that 15
grand yeah you know has a bottle of that
way click on the wall it's 15 here
that's $1,500 that's great that's 1998
three year old 23 year old fourteen
thousand Wow yeah so our boy Wes Chatham
West Chatham has a bottle of Pappy let's
come on bro yeah we gotta break that out
yeah let me just get my beak wet a
little bit I'm gonna Pappy Van Winkle
I'd be out that'd be eyes called
probably been vinca there'd be a treat
your real treat yeah we should have a
little bit of dude we should buy a three
year old waxed 15 grand it's just so
rare you can't you can't get it you
thought yeah but you can find the well
the most careful and expensive distilled
method can be used to create the whiskey
as special as this one this is the same
distillation as our famous 20 year old
Pappy Van Winkle family rest whose Pappy
Van Winkle
happy happy but vinkle yeah well rib and
VIN vinca Rip Van Winkle right you know
the story have Rip Van Winkle falls
asleep wakes up how many years later 15
I should know this see what's the hour
why what why is is so expensive in 1983
when he was 18 year old um Pappy Van
Winkle a senior began working a salesman
for a liquor wholesale we're at though
15 years later okay he owned it that's
1910 okay sour mash whiskey 1872 super
old
we're on she's got the product has been
a cult-like following famous chefs such
as anthe Bourdain Janet Bourdain here's
a question the the Bourbon everyone
everybody wants but can't get keep going
down man style okay I don't get white
White's so cool
like all modern Bourbons van vinca
Bourbons are made primarily from corn
that's disappointing an Asian charred
new American oak barrels
I don't get it man and bat blood do you
know so so if his name is Van Winkle
what's his heritage what do you think
Sweden no Swedish no gets Lanka not bad
not but you're in the area what Dutch
[ __ ] I shoulda known that's right then
he'll old Rip Van Winkle straight Burton
and you had been healthy how long was
Rip Van Winkle asleep I'm gonna say 25
years how but it's off the myth right
it's like you work alone yeah or he just
woke up from a coma I mean I just took a
long [ __ ] nap and I want to be
bothered by years Renne Rip Van Winkle
sleeps for 20 years in imitation of the
old German legend Peter close
consolation I still I'm the fans will
let me know I'm curious why Rip Van
Winkle whiskey so expensive it's not
ripped that is Pappy Van when have you
been drinking probably because it's been
around so long and they take such good
care they release only oh they have very
high standards so just like you the
Ferrari yeah
they just have a c6 they're craftsmen
they got it right why Pappy Bambino
models - they do look cool dude the best
thing I own a fart and I just started
getting into liqueur is I have an old
school that our boy Pablo gave me an
old-school Campari when it was clear
from the 60s
Pablo gave that to ya for being a table
for being awesome that's why you didn't
publish it Wyatt for being awesome I'm
going to scope I actually Steve my boy
own scope but - its Pablo he's got a
couple of bottles of Bland's for me
apparently I don't think so dude I feel
like you're making [ __ ] I got the best
stuff don't tell Brendan uh today's some
44 years later it's funny there's a huge
profit hard to get that's why my father
my father will will get he gets into
Scotch whisky that's the whole thing
he'll drink his Scotch was he expensive
and he'll go ah this is life leave it
there Jim it says hold up dude they
joined Buffalo Trace
van Rico's market manager says he has
increased production every year since
dude on two when it joined forces with
Buffalo Trace which now produces all the
company's whiskey [ __ ] I knew
them buffalo traces are doing so it
causes black market to take
hm-hmm by the way don't be surprised if
the jaboney I mean the Chinese come in
with fakes the way they did with wine
come in with fake fake wines really oh
wow you're seeing fake Yeezys thanks
Chinese yeah
fake bags Louie Vuitton bags I
understand but wine you can tell a fake
though you're seeing a kid with fake
Easy's well but though with the watches
and handbags they make them in the same
factor watches is tough
well not not Rolex it'll make the same
factor you know and I mean China they're
just super fakes now there's some really
good fakes tell you to come to Venice
Beach buy the fakes some the pawn shops
in Denver yeah a little hustle I had on
the side when I was a teenager really
yeah man always making we can definitely
try do you those come on where do you
want those are ugh that they
spray-painted gray really put a comfy
not a sock oh god they're so easy to
tell there there's some good ones they
didn't look like that man for God's
honey West knows what people like I
guess it's the worst [ __ ] I've ever I
think those are like house slippers that
they have that look like Easy's there's
some of those that's interesting those
are fake super fake I don't know what
those are those are terrible yeah I
don't know what to tell you guys hurt my
eyes I might want to especially I agree
those aren't great they're comfy as [ __ ]
though yeah bet I got some look down to
see if I had em over easy thought you'll
be honest what are those I like those
these are Varvatos convert right there I
just slip on into them dude John
Varvatos make some good shoes they make
some cool stuff yeah you want to dress
like [ __ ] tits i a magician got some
tits what's up there what's up bro make
me want to squeeze your tits you want to
suck them you want to suck up tits yep
mmm so I do that to Will Sasso I get him
so mad I go what's up he goes hang go I
was life he goes good I go yeah you're
just hanging around he goes hey what do
you want man I go oh my god what are you
just gonna work out or yes look man I'm
busy I go
they suck your tits yes [ __ ] yeah
will you send me just the most vulgar
tax man oh just like some guy get his
nuts kicked yeah like over and over
sandy [ __ ] dude you do mean I bet you'd
even see it you see the nice heartfelt
message I sent on Instagram today do you
know to me the answer da yep to me
yeah man you're included in it and I
wish you would acknowledge it just a tad
that's not why I do it but I wish you
would've solid dude I didn't know wait
post-its I posted 10 pictures that I've
had for my special that Kourtney my boy
shot I couldn't wait to post them I want
to thank everybody who was involved
specifically you and with Joe Rogan
somebody see this go I think it's the
Sexson picture separate the sexy check
out the picture where were sexing yeah
there's my idea right there'd be oh
that's a great shot that's when he came
in that's a great shot that is where I
came in I remember that look at us
Rebecca silence I'm reading I love okay
I'm loving it it's a long message I'll
read it
look at us look at the crew dude no you
go like show that's a great pick leave
abbot kinney - yep e you go to the next
one chimp that one is where you guys
just dropping knowledge on a brother
that's good not those good pictures that
Courtney played 6r8 shut up the court
look at chose hyper-extended knees
yeah that's a great shot ru Yan I know
that's what I'm looking at right now -
no I'm probably going oh no I think
you're going Oh
oh that's and they'll you my face just
like what is happen I'm looking I'm
looking at his hat you a cab driver from
the 20s hmm hey Mac where to hmm
yeah I can't wait to [ __ ] picture I
wanted to wait like a week to have to
the special these are my favorite
pictures and we settle them frame lick
the whole crew there that's a great shot
good J schwa powerful J shop okay look I
was farms Jason that's the crew man it
looks like Jason looks like he was won
by clop in a carnival
hiya buster looks like you as one yeah
are you guys don't talk stop laughing
that's my twink everybody we're gonna go
every time he walks away he's got him on
a chain well I'll be right back Buster
well Jays not with me in Cleveland this
weekend cuz I forget what he's doing but
hey shop and I have the same hair line
um the clothes yeah I love those clothes
man kid the bone I'll tell you what
though if you want Jason Buster and my
brothers off in a new city these
[ __ ] know everywhere to go
research before I get there we walk
everywhere yeah I have to tell you guys
go I'm gonna take a [ __ ] break how
about that I'm gonna take a break
mmm-hmm that's a great that's great dude
that's the whole crew min that's a great
shot yeah where was I in that your
brother owes me and Rogan probably max
my backstage that's like the people off
not comics right so that's like my man
that's just in our age it that's right
Jason great guy
yeah there's Jay and clop and then
Jason's laughing for whatever reason mmm
very good picture dude thanks Ben
I want I've been waiting to post these
mm-hmm but I figured you won't see
unless I said for the boys right there
look at the brothers brothers let me get
in there
brothers no that's very brothers you're
on the road brothers brothers got to be
there others run should we go eat over
here brothers brothers I want to be part
of the crew they be hanging out okay
guys brothers get Mimi squeezing in
there I think just let me get him be
with us in Vegas
awesome 15 can never get enough of him
think so can never get enough you guys
are coming too aren't you mm-hmm Oh
snaps [ __ ] Vegas hey where we stand we
stand we stand proper what do you want
to stay I want to stay somewhere Prompto
got a night I'll be coming from New York
now now you can have coming from new you
are listen doing my press tour for
complicated it's gonna hurt a little bit
I get you stayed at the circus circus
haha
hey guys with less [ __ ] stay hey guys
here for the circus they wouldn't keep
me there when I was a kid that's we were
my dad haven't stayed at once I find
those hotels to be very depressing I was
there checked into the palms in their
old towers and ice it smelled like
Cologne and there were cigarette stains
and I go 1,000 1,000 limo drivers in
their 40s have stayed here and had a
hooker in this bed I can't I was like if
I had a blue light here I'd be such a
disaster I gotta get him out of here
hotels are where you stay in your hotel
when you come in the city is everything
and for me and for me Palms triggers
negative thoughts right because that's
where I lost a roid Nelson there so
don't get me the Palms go hey shop we'll
give you our master suite I would rather
stay at Circus Circus that's very
interesting remember I lost the fight to
stay two more days and do [ __ ] stuff
with ultimate fighters miserable that's
so man as you're walking around on a
Sunday palms when no one's in the
[ __ ] casino and you lost the base by
your life and get a walk through deep in
the few people or there recognize you of
course by the way of course you lost
you've been fighting a year yeah
fighting Roy Nelson a hilarious you've
been fighting a year and they put you in
with that ridiculous veterans we sign up
one of the 100 UFC a Hall of Famer
actually yeah for sure legitimately mm a
Hall of Famer you'd say best chin maybe
I would say hard right Jones in some
ways Yeah right Johnson's Chin's right
now my right not now silly jokes Chin's
of all time and a ridiculously good
fighter I mean what if if but here's
what's funny about that that fight when
it got sanctioned if it was a regular
fight of course only really got
sanctions cuz we're in a tournament and
Vegas sanction it but I don't know if we
let's say the I just got to UFC which I
went with three fights say I only had
three fights
I got do you have seen all right here's
Roy Nelson Commission's when I caught up
this guy's over 30 fights you have this
kid s3 that's pretty with sanction it
but then boxing they would never let
that happen no but that's just the
nature of the beast but it also it gave
me my platform you know I get to take
one on the chin correctly or behind the
air about knockout and he did that to so
many people you don't see it yeah I do
because I I'm looking for the overhand
right but yeah you don't see that if I'm
out you're looking for dude huh you know
what you're looking for my hands except
my hands are out that's all I step back
I got like this another chair oh you
know I'm here oh good for you two
weekends in a row that's nice yeah do
you not looked at my schedule I get so
many weekends on the road I'm kind of
stressed out about it a lot but gee
that's how you get good no I know I know
dude I know I'm just saying I know six
weeks in a row that's too much
me too much I saw him with I agreed to
all this it's exhausting it's exhausting
you're gonna make a lot of money and I'm
away from the kid I'll do that's the
thing I panic when I'm away from the kid
like for more than three days but yeah I
know I know
were you going we're all you go and
bring this up bring up his schedule so I
can so I can go through this myself
Cleveland awesome hilarities hilarities
have you been there yes and I heard
that's what everyone's the owner is a
guy you want to be when you're his age
that's why Bobby Lee told me it's like
the best owner ever yeah Cleveland you
got Cleveland Burbank is okay easy so
face not really these aren't really we
know this doesn't keep going this
doesn't count this now we got Calgary
okay that's Canada that's that's get a
direct flight but I understand Brea easy
Brad you're home there a little time off
right then I go since II owe Nashville
oh [ __ ]
Portland oh [ __ ] Denver oh you're all
over the country yes that's where it
gets tricky
oh damn be done - now Denver is gonna be
fun however because you're from there
you're gonna have to deal with a lot of
families don't say he's Austin there you
go
cuz you gotta have put people on the
list there's all kinds of stuff that
goes on yeah I know what's complaining
I'll figure it out right yeah for what
your could have been sir you have the
shark attacks I have one um yeah do you
see do got just the leg ripped off by a
great white no was it a great white that
way it was there for sure great light it
was intact I got Tiger - is that Maui
right yeah yeah confirmed great white I
confirm
yep I don't know let's say I'm that's
what Good Morning America said word they
showed a picture of great white you know
they do it you know there's been more
shark attack tropically a tiger there's
been more shark attacks than ever this
already like leading into yeah well it's
a wilderness area I've no we're done in
Hawaii men I've been I've been I've been
I've done a lot of snorkeling out there
and me too Ben yeah saw a bunch of stuff
now or a heels you see you see [ __ ]
nice charlie shark warnings was posted
because they lots of them I read this
they got lots of shark warning sign for
posters and sundogs area where the man
died a day earlier as we got closer I
saw some blood on his stomach they got
looking a little bit more his wrists
look back and a skin on his wrist was
just torn off this is a different guy
then I got some looking closer and his
entire left leg from the knee down was
just missing this is a different guy no
the same guy that's been making the news
yeah and then do you see do you see the
video of them getting him and then put
him on shore he's already dead I I
didn't see that
that's snorkeler off of maori in 2015
was killed not had a bit shitty way to
go i think that's like a bull shark sing
do usually Tigers the one that do it but
they I thought they found the great
white I think so I don't think yeah it's
gonna be tough to know it to pinpoint
which shark well tell that to Good
Morning America because they had a
picture of a great white ehm yeah
they'll show up great white but you know
what hey so just so we're all clear no
one's listening if I get bit by a shark
or killed
just tell everyone's a great white okay
don't tell me the bull shark doesn't
[ __ ] yet alright you know I'm said well
like there's a huge hole sharks are
giants I know but most people don't
think of it it's all about how you spin
the narrative dude shark bite capital
world experienced where is that I was in
Florida Florida dude get the [ __ ] in my
face but this was in Hawaii
let's go some current events I'm glad
you guys had that one though cool let me
pee on my huge so there's quality and
then there's quality you understand you
talking about Rome for the modern man
I happen to know that roan is admired by
other people that make clothing true
alright this and I happen to know that
if I'm a fashion guy I'm a fashion guy
and I like run you know what look at the
website take a look at their gear
alright it's all about premium short
shirts tank tops socks women wear their
own engineers the perfect clothing for
the office maybe got a long flight
community's driving where we got to do
they got your commuter collection okay
and it's the performance alternative to
the everyday work where my buddy wears
it it's sharp
it looks great it's wrinkle-free but
guys if you live close to the bone like
me if you if you like if you say you
like to do some parkour stop crime you
like to do some street fight also but
some lovin make some business deals
cuz I'm an artist but a business meant
you wanna be wrinkle free want to be
wrinkle free cuz you know I'm lazy when
it comes to clothes but I want good
quality wine I want strong smooth line
you know what you want yeah you want to
visit Rome dot-com that's Rho and EECOM
slash fighter and use promo code fighter
to get 20% off your entire first
purchase round coms loan it either own
it up run it up that's what we say grown
up run it up our own die quality slash
eyeliner high quality clothing let's do
this buddy what are we doing so we're
gonna start off with something sad and
progressively get happier
Stanley's former business partner was
arrested in Arizona for elder abuse and
he's claiming that he has never laid a
hand on Stanley and that this is an
accusation from his daughter who's the
one who abused Stanley before he died so
this business partner and Stanley
actually had a falling-out a couple
months before Stanley's death and he
ended up with a restraining order
against this gentleman and yeah he's
trying to say that this is all a big
accusation from his daughter and she was
jealous that him and Stan were so close
I believe it I mean I well I don't know
what do you mean by elder abuse and how
was he getting away with elder abuse
what does that be like
sounds like a general accusation and I
got skeptic I got hippo eyes too here
yeah they don't specify I would
understand that that that this sounds
kind of like I'm like what elder abuse
up Stanley
probably wealthy guy who created
spider-man and everything else huh how
was he gonna eat it what did he come
over and beat him up what are we talking
about there are accusations about him
mishandling Stanley's money though
sure well yeah I'm sure there was all
that but but there's that same exact
slapping sticking around yeah when you
say elder abuse
you gotta get specific and how when that
[ __ ] comes out mm-hmm but yeah on to
some better news so this Wendy's
employee after-hours took a bath in
their sink this video went viral and he
ended up getting fired from his job what
was he so what a clean was he doing it
just to prove that you can still get
past no just like for shits and giggles
for snapchat oh well of course they'd
have to fire you
yeah it's worth good but it's the sink
where they wash their dishes and gross
that's it's actually that sink has got
plenty of bacteria period yeah I mean I
definitely what you washing your abs I
don't want your your groin and your your
poopoo place clean it's hilarious damn
video I saw y'all filming - oh good
today all you fired I'm just the guy who
did it I don't know is it worth firing
him it was just a prank he's just
[ __ ] around right I feel like Wendy's
can't really let stuff like that go
after the whole like a finger in the
chili debacle lose a finger and chill
now but that was a yes [ __ ] yeah
that was [ __ ] way back in the day a
woman said that she found a finger in
her chili and it happened to be her
husband's finger that she somehow had to
move yeah next one yeah yeah
so this 27 year old man had a gun on in
his front pocket
it got triggered and went through his
nutsack into his thigh and before going
to the hospital to get stitched up he
had his girlfriend drive him to his
friend's house to drop off the gun
he's a convicted felon with 13 felonies
so he couldn't get caught with having a
gun while he was in the hospital getting
stitched up this article says that
somehow a balloon filled with weed
slipped out of his butthole while he was
getting stitched up okay they reported
it to the police while he was there
finishing up on him police searched his
car found a pair of jeans that were
bloodied up they're suspecting that it's
the pair of jeans that he accidentally
shot himself in and had a baggie of meth
inside a van ruiner
yeah they then arrested him and while
they were taking him in another balloon
field of marijuana fell out of his ass
oh my god they keep saying that it
slipped out yeah well they probably use
the lubrication that your rump gets
loose you guys feel a little too relaxed
got a little relaxed and that's
hilarious yep
well there are those kids what else you
got
this right here Adam Levine I guess he
wasn't supposed to leave the voice but
he's been acting really messed up
recently why I guess he had like fights
being on the show he's tired of being on
the show I guess it's so much money on
this show do you know the upfront I
don't know much about up fronts but he
was supposed to be out up front and he
was just being like like he didn't want
to be there yeah I'm just yeah the
upfront tell me what it is be you
basically go there and they announced
your show all those stars are interviews
it's not yeah I mean when you're at his
level you you do so much of this and
your life is is constantly these sort of
like you're standing you're having
pictures taken you're answering the same
questions from different media outlets
and it does get a little bit much it
gets for a guy like that boring or you
know he just doesn't want to do it
because it doesn't happen how long have
we been on it 12 years 12 seasons Wow
does anyone know scroll down yeah it was
16 seasons enough yeah he's had enough
yeah I'm sure for him he's like I dude
season 16
got a good body don't take your shirt
off like that but you do have a good
body and I guess cool tattoos but I like
his music I feel like it was eight years
from what I remember he was on the
freight yeah something like that
actually she sings well he's a [ __ ]
he didn't want to do the up fronts thing
or whatever because he had no
contestants left over I guess before
they would have judges with you know
certainly Monica's testa's left over at
the end it would gauge but that he had
none left over see he didn't want to go
to that either because of that he was
like why the [ __ ] am I going yeah plus
you when you have all the money and fame
in the world he's probably [ __ ] it yeah
but for me it was allowed to move on you
see it yeah for me it's time to move on
cool but he was supposed to be on for
next season it's because of this and
then the NBC execs get pissed off that
he's no longer do other [ __ ]
you probably won out already is like one
more season then when the executives get
pissed off him he's like you know what
[ __ ] this I'm out dude and there's a lot
of like you there's like you get ready
backstage you got your change yeah she's
a lot of stuff that to a while you're
sitting there and it can get I don't
know probably add a lot of times to like
well that's that true but a lot of them
are like older seniors who would
critique like on American Idol I was
like Paula Abdul right and like Lionel
Richie so he's still like in the prime
of his [ __ ] yeah here and if I like I
don't be known as the [ __ ] voice guy
yeah and this exit is also a little bit
stage two you cool you want to go with
some noise so you go into something else
he's like a bad boy yeah you got to do
some stuff yeah do you like room five
children Oh way back in the day you
don't like him now I'm sure they're
great I just don't listen to him much
are you a fan cat I agree with chin
actually I like the earlier stuff a
little better there's something now it's
dubbed a good sellout no I just kind of
like their alternative sound more I love
the feeling of I still loved blink until
they became real popular yeah dude I was
with those guys from the jump and then
they got famous completely different huh
or they got a lot better you know it's
blink 182 Travis's band yeah yeah well
what's it maroon 5 is his yes room 5 he
can sing man I've listened I was like oh
here's that voice that crazy like real
nasally high voice yeah he makes that
again again you're talking about a guy
he's probably he's probably a wealthy
Jewish kid from Los Angeles who was
raised in music and in performance since
of at a very young age and you know just
[ __ ] him got good he got good man look
at him
I still love is here I hate when he
asked them good-looking kids to hate
Mohawks dude
Mohawks trigger me yeah I don't know who
he's from LA right he's probably from
Brentwood grew up in Brentwood no not
him uh I know he does recording all the
time so he knows that is he from
Brentwood I thought he was from like the
valley or somewhere maybe somewhere like
that I think maybe broward either way
you don't get you know that I guarantee
he's been in music class and dance class
in acting class since day one Beverly
Hills Adams a Bolivian purchased thirty
five point five million dollar home in
Beverly Hills so you want me to do what
look at Wikipedia for a sec you'll see
I'm gonna guess where he's from
originally yeah I'm gonna guess I know
he's from California you're saying where
Adam Levine was born Los Angeles I'm
Noah look dude look when he was born
bro at our JT yeah special day you [ __ ]
all right Pisces shout to my pi see
brother to his dad Fredrik we found her
of a retail chain and Fredrik that's got
some money he has brother Michaels who
have siblings
came from a good family they were Jewish
while maternal grandmother was a
Protestant Levine considers himself
Jewish though according to Jewish
Chronicle he's spiritually but not
reasonable just says he's born in LA not
exactly where but there's there's
there's a tradition culturally of like
you know you you you become rbr be an
artist be you know be educated be keeps
going down it's supported you did study
in New York yeah he sees stuff he's so
good he's disciplined and he studies so
you can see his body the guy's you know
he's got he's button-down
he's [ __ ] knows what he's doing would
have been successful anything does oh
yeah
all right this one's bad I has to do
with a cat like someone kicking a cat
who's these viral videos the cat that
does
helicopter that's it jeez this is so
messed up the way hard if he does a
helicopter but it does resemble that a
little bit see this guy like was trying
to pet a cat all nicely like being sweet
to the cat the cat finally started
walking onto him and then he's just
stalker kicks it he'll maybe I haven't
seen this one oh no mine won't the guy's
not being mean to the cat okay this is
to provide well here's a kick this is
terrible and they're trying to locate
this guy everything I see is it's from
the UK's somewhere from the UK that's
all the information I got he's laughing
how jacked up is that what what let's
find this oxygen thief yep oxygen thief
yesyes he's breathing he's taking yeah
why is he alive he's he sure
well what bina can recognize this is not
a biggest jerk I wonder what the I'm
sure that's a pretty clear video I'm
sure they're gonna find him right helps
I don't know but what the [ __ ] was he
thinking posting we'll see what you use
you look what you do is this you find
him you post his picture up and tell his
reward just tell tell his employer so he
doesn't get a job he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that that's that where that's where
public shaming I'm not a fan that's
writing public shaming works you're oh
you're that kind of a piece of [ __ ] you
kick cats you kick innocent animals like
that don't want you working at my place
no hell no let them know there's no way
this could be faked all right now here's
buddy film it too should probably be
dealt with as well why is he laughing so
hard the piece of [ __ ] just seems like
he's hang out together yeah you're right
how about that guy walk by and punch
those two women that crazy guy there's a
lot of this guy's not crazy this guy's a
[ __ ] I guess pshew so you'd see crazy
people that kill somebody on the street
cuz they're crazy they see demons one
thing that's a piece of [ __ ] that guy's
not crazy that guy's dead stone-cold
sober just a cruel person and a bully so
you know hamstring them huh maybe lose a
foot there's half a foot what have
[ __ ] god I gotta Terry kick him in
the gut what's that should have someone
kicked him in the guy what's his name I
have who's got the crazy killer Bose I
have Barboza our guarantee
tear until [ __ ] yeah I just break his
ribs give him a couple cracks it's not
the way life works though is it what
else you got this right here this has
been making the news Quentin Tarantino a
reporter was talking about how Margot
Robbie Margot Robbie didn't get enough
speaking parts
did you watch this part no but I'll
bring with me I'll play this for to
agree with him I'll play this for him
then you'll see how he reacts by the way
just a bunch of dime pieces
she looks so freaking good here to put
your dick away New York Times report in
the harbor of Muslim liberal man far
less in your film she was in with
Leonardo in Wall Street I Tanya this is
a you know person with a great deal of
acting talent and yet you haven't really
given her many lines in the movie and I
wondered I guess that was a deliberate
choice on your part and I just wanted to
know why that was that we don't hear her
actually speaking very much and Margo I
wanted you to also comment about being
in the film in this part well I just
reject your hypothesis so that's all he
said and Margot Robbie had a really good
answer but it's yours right right she
should be yeah and and and you're an
[ __ ] that that that's the lady that
was asked yeah she's yeah literally
activist okay tell you that this got a
standing ovation the question did no I'm
saying no not the question if it was
like cinema I'm moving especially in the
jacket for the movie gonna standing out
here with your activism you [ __ ] it's
the closest thing he's come to pulp
fiction results oh god I can't wait to
like it this is the kind of [ __ ] you
deal with these [ __ ] so what's what's
uh whenever she says there is Robbie
sorry Robbie says amazing stuff right
why that was that we don't so after she
says that I like I said like I said
earlier I I I always look it to the
character and what the character is
supposed to serve meat to the story
I know mind I
think the moments that I got on-screen
gave an opportunity to honor Sharon and
the lightness I don't think it was
intended to delve deeper than like Brad
also mentioned I think the tragedy
ultimately was the loss of innocence and
to really show those wonderful sides of
her I think could be adequately done
without speaking I did feel like I got a
lot of time to explore the character
even without dialogue specifically which
is an interesting thing because I often
do look to the interaction with other
characters to inform me on the character
rarely do I get an opportunity to spend
so much time on my own as a character
going through a day-to-day existence
that was actually an interesting thing
for me to do as an actor I actually
really appreciated the exercise and felt
that I could deliver what I wanted to on
screen beautiful right
yeah she's she could have spoken I said
I'd go look at okay I'd like today's I
think I got a question
not where the questions is more of a
comment I work for the guy time she's
not really look at you go huh look at
you up there huh feeling good about
things okay yeah I'm gonna watch it were
you watching it um yeah I know people
always looking for somebody complaining
about what else you get this guy the
doctor from botched I know that guy dr.
Nassif yeah he was saying that if
arleigh Artie Lange were to clean up his
act and the only reason is saying clean
up cuz he would do his he'll fix his
nose for free he can fix it through it
with the way it should be looking but if
he does cocaine again it's just gonna
make it worse and damage it worse so
he's saying get so quit entirely
he's like the top knows doctor in the
world - yeah he's like one a big
big-time nose doctor had a long talk
with all he does his nose I've talked
with him about not only noses but he was
sitting next to someone - he whose nose
he did I mean goes now look at that nose
that's a nose really yeah oh he
definitely helped Artie but yeah I get
what he's saying yes to be sober
otherwise just a waste of time I mean I
don't know what happened what so I guess
the cartilage disintegrates how did that
weapon of its continuing to still snort
coke probably hmm how about this this
hiker in Hawaii was lost for 17 days she
was finally found and she survived off
berries river water water smart in
Hawaii it feels like you wouldn't get
lost in Hawaii it says here at river
water and smarts is how she survived so
she's supposed to be a doctor of
physical therapy and then she also
didn't bring her cell phone and the way
she got lost is she tried to do a
different trail that she's never done
before mm-hmm
then she tried to meditate fell asleep
woke up didn't know where she was and
that's how she got lost and they're
breaking her ankle - I think her leg
well and then she's okay
there was a GoFundMe page for her that
her friend did and then it raised her on
$75,000 or whatever and they took some
money of that to hire a helicopter guy
to get her friends to drop in to find
her and that's how he spotted her yeah
that's cool yeah Wow that's really cool
damn that GoFundMe is powerful man it is
and that's her get severely sunburned 17
days in Maui she I lost yeah on a hiking
trail mmm are you guys um oh this one's
is really interesting just look at these
pictures here right there's people
running around that didn't work out on
the lake space I'll just play for you so
people were jumping around and running
into a drive-thru and it's like how why
are these people doing a chick-fil-a see
I'm all jumping into the drive-thru
window window seeking shelter in the
storm
holy moly so there's a tornado people
started running inside the driver window
they're trying to get them to one
chicken and does this Oh fun it got
crazy
buthe Oklahoma thing we don't to worry
about its tornado
yeah have you ever been in a tornado
sure happen in Denver the least when I
was a kid there's turning as we to go
the basement right now you get a snacks
you go to the basement you just here and
you could go outside and see it
tornadoes are how about average traffic
jam everybody died I mean I got ten
within two weeks ten people died you
don't look at what time jam they're
giving out way too many permits and the
people that they're getting parents to
you aren't trained so they're taking
longer than normal are you kidding me
look at this so people are dying on the
way back
good air what's called um so much Eric
it's it's well it's our high altitude
poisoning
yes very little air and your body you
freeze to death everything's down your
tissue so now even Mount Everest is
overpopulated people want to do that
people want the I would love to do that
but why I wouldn't I'd always feel like
an ego things you know I don't want to
climb in the through 10 deaths I'd like
to climb like to a jungle or something I
don't know this is the art of suffering
yeah ten deaths this is for people I
think that want to show off to other
people like I've climbed down
underground yeah yeah I mean while you
die look at that [ __ ] so dangerous those
are people just waiting so that you wait
for people to come down I mean they're
climbing up slowly but they're also
waiting for people to go self says
stupid add all that up and then people
are dying stupid that's so crazy so
they're asking for the government to
stop giving so many tournaments out to
people that are trained holy [ __ ] man
well you want one more sure some people
stole Wagyu beef inside of a purse but
if you look at the person that stole it
that's the interesting part to me so
here's the image of it my go beef yeah
what are you gonna wag what do you think
stole it oh that girl in her half so
check out how she grabs it and just
slaps in her purse it is expensive you
gotta know you're on camera love yes you
gotta know this is a high dinner just
worth it it's worth hundreds of dollars
and I guess people have been trying to
steal some other waggy there before and
this woman got caught they found out who
she was so she ran to another
person someone was waiting and they took
the beef there's another accomplice
she took the fall for the one she also
shells also if we get away oh wow all
said they won't do anything what do you
mean you won't get in trouble for this
you'll just get booked and though really
yeah you get a fine or something that
it's really hard for stores to good
press charges they're just like you
stole mean Wagyu beef yeah yeah it's all
fat
they said it probably melted by the time
they got to the their house because it
wasn't a nice it's all fat I'll use all
fat yes I mean they're mostly they raise
the beef is so ridiculous new round
I'm not a big Wagyu guy they massage it
they wanted they feed it crazy you are a
wag you fan number on on sushi Julia
yeah add it right a melting it off that
kind of be I think it's so artificial it
seems gross so tasty though yeah tender
juicy no fat we get some new boots no
because these are my $1,000 from
Wolverine I live close to the bone it's
the only thing looking rough though huh
yeah but I'm such a rough dude I'm a
rough cat you know Brian he's a rough
cat but I do get a get some yeah you
don't want Varvatos today maybe which
one my Diaz
oh no man will say behind it Century
City has one though I think they have a
sale gone you should go an alibi too
they got a big one until they you know
since soon there's the Barbados in there
get some new boots
my family's did a movie the kids so I
might go to I'm alone the house Malibu
but it's still Frank Grillo by yourself
now grill is there my boy Frankie just
you guys hanging out dude yeah I'll eat
some food that's it
alright America we love you happy
Memorial Day I love that you know our
men and women in uniform
yes for making the ultimate sacrifice
this is an important time and an
important time remembrance and we are a
great country and Brian will go get new
boots for everybody how do I go get new
boots um that's how you're gonna on
earth that's exactly--it new boots do
exactly right um back on the road back
on the road here I go again
here I come on I think son go um you
know stay yeah I forget what's yeah I go
yasya dude I'm in Cleveland this week
Thursday Friday Saturday
hilarities Cleveland come on out dog
pound Cleveland Thursday Friday Saturday
and then after that the Fung week
Burbank that is June 8 I'm in Burbank at
what's the place in Burbank called brown
flappers flapper times come flap with me
at Burbank's flap on comm flap with me
Vegas Brian and I that show is almost
sold out one night only at the Orleans
in Las Vegas Nevada
then Calgary just hit as well Brea up as
well T fat K dot com thank you for
everyone that watched my special you
guys are amazing if you haven't seen it
go to Showtime comp remote job you'd
watch it for free for 30-days get you
some and if you're on t fat k calm i
want you to get some tickets if you're
in indianapolis or anywhere near indeed
june 6 7 8 looking forward to hanging
out with your old buddy Matt Mitrione
yeah Las Vegas as you know the 15th or
lean showroom did Tempe Tempe improv
let's go June 20 21 22 I'm coming coming
hard coming true
I'll be ready mainly coming though yeah
I'm mainly coming this is a fine kid
well